We've all heard the saying, "food is love",
but for Latrice MacArthur, it holds especially true.
She's a chef and a teacher and the founder of
Wellness with Bella, an afterschool program
focused on healthy eating and meals for those in need.
Please welcome Latrice.
(audience applause)
Hello!
Hi, nice to meet you.
Oh my gosh, you look so beautiful.
You look great, as usual.
Oh, thank you.
This is a ton of hair, makeup and wardrobe, trust me.
And I was curious what inspired you
to jump into community action and start your program.
So a little over 10 years ago,
when the former first lady Michelle Obama
started her, Let's Move initiative,
and she asked for chefs to come in
and volunteer in elementary schools.
And I was working as a private chef at that time,
and decided sure I can go in
and the anticipated volunteering,
maybe a day or two, possibly a week.
But after spending time with the kids,
I saw a tremendous need to be able to educate them
on food, and nutrition, and culinary skills, as well.
And within a year, the nonprofit was started.
And you discovered during the pandemic,
like a new sense of purpose, will you tell us about that?
Absolutely.
So initially, when we got the call that schools
were gonna be closed.
Just like everyone else, we anticipated
that it would only be for two weeks.
And then we said, sure, we can figure that out,
and get out a couple of hundred meals.
And so I pulled together our volunteers,
and then we figured out how to deliver.
And that couple of hundred meals that we anticipated
has turned into now, 15,000 meals that we have been able
to deliver.
Oh my goodness!
(audience applause)
I mean, Latrice!
You are the angel that we all hope exists on the planet,
because when we all watched what happened at the beginning
of school closures, it was so heartbreaking, so scary.
And even on your website,
the mission statement says, change a life today.
And that's so simple and so impactful,
and that's exactly what you're doing,
but over and over and over again.
You know, and it seems so simplistic.
It doesn't seem like it should be an issue,
but hunger is a huge issue.
And, you know, we can't expect our children to go to school
and be able to function, and thrive
if they have not had a proper meal.
And so this is my mission to make sure that
not only are we providing the meals as far as students,
but also making sure that they are ready to thrive in school
to be able to close some of those success and education gaps
that exists in these communities.
Well, thank goodness for you Latrice.
And I heard that you're a big admirer of Anne Burrell.
Is that true?
That is so true.
I love her, by the way, obsessed.
I love her.
I love her style, I love the way she, her recipes,
the way she brought us into the kitchen.
I really adore her.
Oh, well that's good cause she adores you too.
Guess who's here? It's Anne Burrell.
(audience applause)
(women squealing)
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, look how,
How cute are you?
And that smile is just infectious.
Oh, and hi Drew!
Hi Anne.
When I heard about you, Latrice,
and all of the wonderful stuff that you do,
for so many people, it actually makes me weepy.
I'm a huge fan of Chicago and I go there kind of regularly.
So I feel like the next time I'm in town,
I'm gonna like swing by, and maybe
I'll help you cook for a day or something.
Yes!
And I would love that.
Not again, to be a weirdo, but I want in on that.
Okay.
And we at the show wanted to donate to your mission,
and to the families in Chicago.
So our friends at Trifecta,
an organic meal delivery service,
are giving you 500 meals to distribute
throughout your community.
(audience applause)
And I thank them so much for that.
That's fantastic, thank you so much!
Oh, that's gonna help so many kids, thank you!
It's not enough, but it's a start.
And Anne, did you want to add anything to that?
Well, Latrice, everything that you do is so important.
So the people at Trifecta want to give you 500 more meals!
So that's 1000 meals.
Oh my God.
(audience applause)
I mean, all the work that you do is so important
and we just wanna keep that smile as bright,
as electric, as it absolutely is.
Absolutely.
Thank you guys, so much.
Oh, this is amazing.
Our kids are gonna love this, thank you.
Thank you to Trifecta for helping us, do this.
And Anne Burrell, I love you so much,
I can't believe I'm gonna do this with you.
I see you Drew Barrymore, I love you.
Latrice, I mean, you are just a rock star
and thank you guys so much for including me in this.
Aww.
Yes.
Thank you both.
Your blessing is so exciting, thank you.
Oh Latrice and Anne.
Oh, be sure to check out the new season
of Worst Cooks in America.
Premiering April 25th at 9:00 PM,
8:00 PM central on the Food Network.
(upbeat music)